you
our rumen arena
let's roll here 30 minutes of one-minute
regular chess Fight Club let's play fast
and maybe go for gambit stuff okay we're
going into a French Oh I was not
expecting that let's do this no matter
what and I'm really looking to open up
the position clean okay the queen is
gone and are they going to resign let's
insert this check and take here if they
block no let's open this position up all
right bishop here give a check rook here
and I should have taken the pawn maybe
take care no matter what they're still
in a pin and they cannot defend that
Bishop again they resigned back to
tournament okay three twos only three
games have finished up to this point 60
almost 70 players ven Koji let's try e4
I'm not a fan of berserk unless I really
need to at the very end okay let's get
my bishop back here to secure stuff on
the G file
give me the H file to play with let's
queenside castle I'm looking for d5
stuff let's get my King here push twice
yeah just to break up the pawns I know
I'm losing upon but still gonna do that
the bishops gonna block yeah okay why
was I not moving just then let's get a
flight square I guess okay let's give
this check
I'm not playing this well I'm down upon
for what exactly
nothing what's that move I have no idea
I'm still down upon I'm still down upon
I'll take that pawn on h7 maybe maybe I
just I do not like my position at all
I guess we'll to go here clean trade
yeah I really don't want to clean trade
my knight is within checking distance
this is no good no good at all okay I
was being sneaky they're not quite sure
where my knight is going I know where
their king is going I don't like it I'll
have to throw in tricky checks and stuff
not cool 18 seconds okay can I get that
pawn okay their King isn't gonna make
any headway start running with my pawn
here I have c4 covered they missed that
can grab there get a queen fast don't
allow stalemates here and mate next they
have a pawn to move back to tournament
that was terrible I gave up a bond for
nothing
oh okay now I have to play someone who
was a master at puzzles chess puzzles
knight c6 let's go with the kingside
fianchetto
let's stop e5 stuff all right Knight g4
it's clearly stopped let's get Mike we
know grabbed their night and then play
my bishop here wrote to c8 a6 b5 we're
gonna have a dark square bishop game
here Queen here we're gonna have this
trade focus on the dark squares their
King is gonna approach and I can do this
right
defend this pawn
it's probably here c4 is now weakened
let's go here strike at their center a
little bit back up this is a convenience
car for my bishop and this is a
convenience square for my knight prop oh
I just dropped a pawn for no good reason
we're gonna play with the tricky night
versus their bishop now all right
double up and then still look for b5 I'm
down upon but I should be having some
play here the rook off of that file
that's a good move there bishop they
have to be very careful about that they
might lose their bishop soon let's take
this and maybe take their Bishop yeah
let's do this I'm gonna play here next
and then rook to be to get the rook get
behind there and okay we're gonna let me
throwing this check actually okay I
might be able to mate somehow let's play
here threatening mate no I'm not
threatening mate oh ha that was a bad
miscalculation at least I'm in a good
spot here with my rook okay I got to go
faster
throw in some time burners let's take
here
run fast please they resigned back to
tournament stuff to commentate when
you're down on time oh man
okay yeah yeah that was really mate it
takes F three that's the ballgame isn't
it no it's not you still gotta play
chess because you miscalculated John
Tiger one okay
not sure why I say certain names like I
do I don't have good reasons so if that
those kind of questions are happening in
the chat I just don't know I don't know
where it comes from
let's support my knight on e5 there
might be some tactics against f7 let's
try it and yeah it should be working out
now let's take here let's make it simple
to take like this here and then castle
next I cost some time I'm up material
but and you know simplify I love to
pawns now not happy with how I'm playing
this actually I could do this because of
back rank stuff even if they double up I
still have this move with back rank
ideas so at least they're Brooke isn't
going to get active okay they're night I
could hunt him down I'm winning upon or
simplifying night here give him a kick
okay I'm definitely trading down here
this is a one King and pawn ending to
improve my King position g5 f6
what in the world just happened to the
board it's slanted the selected board
camp it whoa
what was that about did you see that or
am I going crazy here is it just my eyes
or did you see that
what just happened there somebody tell
me why did the board go slanted on me
like that what did I do to deserve that
back to tournament they're down no they
resigned the board went slanted there
that was that was weird you're going
maybe we were both going too fast and
the board cannot could not handle the
speed and they made that maybe that's
what it was it was heating up and the
board changed change shape from the heat
from the speed from the speed the the
sheer speed of the pieces anyhow that
game is over and done with you have to
focus on luminosity okay Carol Carl and
still we're gonna maybe think about
launching a Jeep on right away why not
what's stopping us
rook g1 on takes
let's take care it's post-op night and
let's let's roll here let's Rumble sacks
and stuff let's keep going sacrifices on
g6 definitely sacrifices on g6 everybody
loves g6 h7 okay let's take material and
then go here look for f4 that's a pin
let's think about d5 as well let's play
here first
well that's baby suit stuff you know
okay um where do my TAC go nowhere
okay let's do this first let's take here
are you capture with my queen I'd be
threatening mate on g7 there's a check
just get out of the way it's right mate
on g7 they missed that back to
tournament 20 minutes remain 18 16 14 13
in anybody's game alright let's go with
some space and
leaders right there Space Invader we're
gonna go with a fianchetto they're gonna
play b5 no I'm gonna dance around with
my knight and they're gonna stop me from
getting into c5 and I'm gonna remind
them about their each pawn hopefully he
could be dangerous
let's take King g7 soon I'm in a pin
it's not comfortable let's do this first
I have an idea
get off of this diagonal first and
foremost so they take I have this move
maybe rook e1 first is an idea I want to
anchor my knight in here that's a
monster night threatening here and here
dangerous nests I will take here twice
they're gonna take back okay there
should be something juicy here real
juicy that's probably not it but we're
gonna run with it okay that's probably a
very good move okay no light-square
bishop no trade not so fast there goes
my bishop oh they didn't see it that's a
freebie he was a hanging bishop right
there oh I just dropped my queen this is
not good let's go back beautiful attack
oh look could use a rook I'm still in
this uncomfortable pin here okay I'm
guarding stuff barely why am i doing
that move bishops are animals I get made
it soon the board slanted again ah no
that's the last thing I need it's a
slanted board
get out of here slanted board I gotta
just make any moves
anything I'm down on time by a mile
I can't even blame the slanted board
with that ah man that got too wild too
wild 22 2016 okay another caro-kann
mainline okay yeah I really should have
played that different tempo against the
bishop this should be really useful no
okay let's take here let's go here first
Queen f3
maybe not long off let's do this
actually queenside castle and takes 95
let's throw the 92 pin let's go here
still I have pressure against this so
there's no castling it's not as easy at
least Knight takes Knight there's a
discovered attack after I recapture by
the rook and let's let's come back here
same story here bishops now hitting the
Queen they might miss that they're on my
clean let's do like this rook up
I couldn't he's also free you could just
take a free piece instead of pinning it
okay now we're gonna crash through here
no matter what I didn't even realize
they had that block let's take here and
here even if they take that he's gonna
run fast hopefully keep running rook up
over give a check it's not quite check
but we're ready for check now still G
file there's a queen
give me soon where's the mate there it
is back to tournament 24 20 to 18 were
at about the halfway point at 18 I'm not
in streak land
the glass we'll just leave it at that
okay let's see about the glass here okay
this is this is a fine contributing to
move am I gonna move I realize it was my
turn I have the sound here to help me
alright let's play here back up get my
rook to d8 I'm gonna gain a tempo
against my bishop let's back up no
matter what
alright let's push in the center I have
a majority do I not let's get rid of
their beasts on g2 their master defender
I think about piling up on this weak
point now okay he's crashing through I'm
up I'm up a full rook now no full rook
let's grab a pond whine up my boy
structures crushed here
stop that pond from moving any further
just get rid of their tricky night and
all should be well oh boy get out of
there they could take that pond but I'll
take their night directly just want to
get rid of him he's a pest you gotta go
buddy
sick of you king here's a fork I could
take that rook
I missed that let's go here first King F
wanna have the fork
okay now I'm promoting pushing right
through are their mates
okay this isn't uh this isn't quick
meeting to happening soon let's take
care
let's check and that's me sneaky one
back to tournament 32 22 2000 12 points
Bob Sheppard I gotta do some crazier
things I think yeah I definitely have to
do some crazier things hmm I could
actually take that that was very helpful
there's a quick mate
32:24 23 dragon okay I gotta stop with
this d4 stuff okay let's grab some space
let's also throw the H pun let's hang on
to my strong point on e5 h5 happening
soon let's continue swing all the way
through here let's looks weird in
trouble with their bishop at some point
it's a pin this night release the
pressure on d4 let's get rid of him and
then play g4 now I'm going to capture on
Knight h6 because at the end I'll be oh
they missed that I have that square
covered and it take here I'll sack back
queenside castle okay I'm prepared to
just take here and I'm going to take
there clean trade I really don't want I
want to get rook g1 in because they have
a lot of pieces on that's on that file
clean g1 right now clean is close to
trapped Bishop h6 next Queen h3 is the
only safe Square this is crumbling
oh right here I have this defendant I
didn't I was forgetting okay so this is
correct
clearly I'm winning a lot of stuff gonna
move I resign they resigned back
determine where do we stand
34 34 28 25 11 minutes 11 seconds remain
okay
John Madden oh boy
you gotta play fast because we know he
will
gotta keep pace not sure why I'm going
for that Bishop move they did not yet
fianchetto
let's stop them from playing Bishop h6
and let's get this in okay why did I do
that they're gonna take here okay at
least they're not gonna get the B file
open let's move that H pawn I need to
get castled soon actually I don't want a
castle let's go here Queen c8 not sure
what I'm doing with this move b5 I guess
ok Queen c3 if allowed it's a very
active Queen passed pawn bishop here
stuff bishops are really really strong
bishop here next let's get that move in
first double up I'm fine with that trade
King here ok let's trade a little bit
and I'm winning some material here they
might push no I thought they might play
E for my other pawn working King here
should be fine
secure my pawn there might even be mates
yeah they pulled the oh why am i giving
that pawn up so easily
oh I should not have allowed that why
would I ever give that pawn up
no idea okay let's try this again now
that their King has left here f4 they're
gonna get my pawn but I'll be getting
here and now it's time to start pushing
I have a time edge keep pushing it could
block this I'm getting a clean very soon
they might resign I think they will they
resigned back to tournament where do we
stand 36:32 oh he's not on fire anymore
thirty six thirty to twenty five less
than nine minutes to go this is the guy
that beat me up I gotta get this guy
back okay alright let's push the knight
to a different home I'm gonna be really
aggressive with this one see how it
works out okay I get there light square
bishop I have excellent play against the
they're light squares let's eliminate
their defender take care Queen here
Knight g4 is deadly night here I'm
playing here and I think everything is
collapsing that's an annoying move still
go here a triple up okay they're gonna
play f3 and you know let's just let's
throw this check in first I'll be sneaky
I'm gonna come back Knight moves here
not quite let's do this I'll try it
again my knight needs a new home he's
ready to be trapped huh dropping that
pawn
let's see if I could put him to you is
to put the h-file to use their queen
should be trapped soon no just take that
night um take with the pond I want to
keep their Queen right there oh I could
trap their queen with my knight I didn't
even realize that
whoo okay this is gonna work out I got a
night okay back to tournament return to
tournament 3736 one point off he still
is not in streak mode he had another
speed bump less than seven minutes
remain
36 okay
now let's keep going let's start off
with efore in this one let's look to
build a center let's see how they
address that all right some dark square
weaknesses let's try H 5 and not allowed
and this seems like a good square okay
Bishop here I feel like I want to play
g4 okay that's really weakening this
square now take with my queen she's
really active queenside castle rook to
e1 g4 I still I'm thinking about
let's take with the Queen improve her
position the knight can't move I'm
pressure here let's do this I don't care
about my night either I just want to
play h5 okay this is a matin - that was
very helpful back to tournament 40 I
have a lead 40 3731 six minutes remain
okay let's try and extend the lead all
right
break up there Pandu oh maybe not
okay let's try this and then Knight to
f6 okay are they gonna take that night
out let's do this first okay I'm fine
with this this is very good for black I
want to get my light squared Bishop on
the main diagonal soon take him out I
don't want that pawn I don't care about
him I'm on this diagonal maybe I
shouldn't have allowed that capture I
could have taken here first maybe King
side castle soon okay oh this is a
wonderful square no on c3 let's get my
knight their Queen d5 she's a beast
let's take here I'm on the Queen and
rook yeah let's take some material get
all my pieces working they're playing
without their Bishop he's a
upon Queen d5 queen takes D very active
Queen G too tough to defend all these
entry points here
I guess open it up a little bit get the
c5 square I guess double get to c2 and
there are two minor pieces are
struggling to play here Brooksie too
soon or book to c3 they resigned back to
tournament 44 38 36 less than five
minutes remain okay let's keep going oh
this is the guy that's in second this is
a big one okay let's go with this and
build in the center okay let's play
Knight here actually it makes life
difficult I believe for them to do
pushes in fact I could have taken here
maybe I should have done that okay rook
on a to d1 okay this is a good square
they're dropping d6 how to take it with
my queen okay they're giving some
material d6 remains weak though b3 just
to consolidate maybe a four involved get
all my pieces working rook to e1 Bishop
to f1 I should have maybe done that a
move sooner let's back up
he takes B we're just recapturing I'm
soon to move my bishop by the way and
have the the pawn
let's go here actually stay up at the
opposite the bishop maybe Bishop to a5
okay Queen trade I'm fine with let's
actually take with the night cuz it
would be a fork maybe get that fish out
more trades kick that night away they
didn't react to that one they missed
that some of a piece I'm in check let's
get a flight square we don't need any
accidents happening and probably pin the
bishop and attacked of a show they might
resign less than 10 seconds they
resigned back to tournament that was a
big one
was the one that was on my heels
although there's this guy here 12 points
though that's too much
10 point lead 48 38 36
okay let's try f4 mm I wasn't expecting
f5 let's not do anything in the center
just yet let's throw this check in Queen
to e5 on g6 the rook is picked up now
and I'm on the knight twice kind of move
the knight I didn't they got a block
with the Queen or Bishop let's get some
more development in Castle Knight takes
pawn Knight here as well maybe should
have done that one move sooner okay this
is collapsing
Bishop's falling and queen or knight
entering back to tournament they
resigned 52-38 less than two minutes two
minutes remaining in this 187 players
all right Vincent
again let's get the center let's say I
actually have another pawn involved in
the center I take with my knight I get
this advance in okay let's recapture
with my queen maybe quick strike at f7
actually I'll take with my bishop
instead now that he's on that square
let's get more development in all my
pieces are not yet working okay let's
stop the expansion with b5 let's force
the situation here at the bishop Knight
b6 I'm expecting let's react here I have
Queen h3 pressure on h7 okay can't do
that
defend me five it's an idea they might
want to pile up on that although I do
have e5 if the pressure becomes too much
let's give her a kick I don't know what
I really accomplished with that lockdown
on these instead of dropping my a pawn
before I double okay there we go slanted
board alert okay
watch out for the slanted board and get
you every time
okay
it's very weakening but oh I didn't even
see that
that's not cool they have an enormous
night enormous I think I need to find it
I should have gotten rid of him much
much sooner
let's do it now oh okay
this is this is good a piece this one's
not gonna finish the tournament why's
just going for time burning stuff and
they're down on time but the term
intended before that back to terment and
there we go final standings alright
52 we pull it up here fifty two forty
one thirty eight thirty six all right to
the eighty how many eighty-seven of you
I took part in this one where we had
some issues of slanted chess boards good
games aw I'm sure that's something that
will be fixed not too long from now but
that was wacky